good afternoon ladies and gentlemen I'm
Zainab Badawi and it's my great pleasure
to be moderating this particular panel
it's also wonderful to be in the
beautiful city of Stockholm with the
very charming Swedish people you
encounter at every corner and it's very
nice to meet new friends as well as
reacquaint myself with old friends so
this session is about the role of food
what role does food play in our lives so
I'm hoping that we'd be able to answer
this question from different
perspectives from my panel behind me
looking at the cultural sense the role
that food plays in our lives in helping
define what we mean by being human and
also the role that food plays in
development as well as in health and
nutrition so various manifestations of
this question I hope that after your
post launch slump that we'll be able to
wake you up a little bit i'm going to
start straight away Professor Richard
Wrangham you studied zoology at Oxford
and Cambridge subsequently so you really
are
some alrighties come back thank you so
and then you you are now currently a
professor at Harvard University you
wrote a recently very acclaimed book
called Catching Fire what make how how
cooking made us human you want to send
us all back into the kitchen do you know
so looking at this question i'll just
say very quickly by way of a preamble
both you and I a year ago visited that
one separately I hasten to add a unique
tribe in Africa in Tanzania in the Rift
Valley near Lake y SE near the on goro
un'goro crater and of course as we know
paleontologists and archaeologists
believe that this is the cradle of
mankind it's where human beings
originated and we encountered a tribe
that's described as unique in the world
unique because they are the last big
hunter-gatherers in the world there are
hunter-gatherer societies elsewhere in
the world but these ones are unique
because they're big hunter gatherers and
they live in the way that humans have
lived for more than ninety-nine percent
of our history so they hold unique and
many insights into how we live during
what you might call I suppose the stone
age and I observed as you did Richard
their eating habits and I found those
extremely fascinating because the men
hunt and the women are the foragers
rather than gatherers they forage
because as well as getting fruits and
berries and so on that grow wild they
also will catch you know little rodents
mice and so on so having visited the
tribe is called the heads are bowed
tribe what did you take away in terms of
their the role of food in their lives
and what insights it's held into our
origins okay I'm going to pick up on
just one little aspect and it's true for
every human that we know of so I study
chimpanzees and my day job and if you
got to make
no yes okay so people go out to try and
make movies about two chimpanzees they
want to go out and see them making tools
and do incredibly things with theory of
mind and have some kind of cultural
behavior and they get really really
bored because all they do is eat
chimpanzees if you do a time and motion
study they're spending about six hours a
day chewing so I in our society we spend
less than an hour a day chewing this is
not a reply to the meal that you linger
over with your loved one or whatever you
know you might spend a lot of time at
the dining table but the actual amount
of times venturing is very very little
and so from a big perspective of what
kind of species are we and what kind of
role does food play in our lives it's
fascinating to go not just to America
but all the way to the huds our Bay with
a completely different kind of
subsistence system and still the same is
true the evening meal is the critical
locus of feeding time and all sorts of
social events happen around it but the
overall position that I come fascinated
by when I think about the role that food
is played in our lives is incredibly
small because it's only less than an
hour a day if if we were eating our food
raw in the way that chimpanzees do we
would be spending something like eight
hours a day chewing we have been
remarkably freed by this this adoption
of cooking evolutionarily cooking makes
food soft mg rich we don't need toast
memo so much time on it so of course you
know the the problems that we are
addressing in this panel and in this
whole day about food security and food
sustainability I don't don't don't get
affected by that nevertheless just very
quickly those shoes you say we only
spend an hour but there had zombie I
mean I went out with them hunting and
the women foraging they spend a lot of
their day trying to obtain food one way
or another they don't have any
refrigeration obviously
what they eat if they can't catch a big
animal they have to eat very quickly but
you're right obviously they did cook and
they SAT around the table so obviously
our teeth over years became our jaws
became smaller our teeth became smaller
and our brains became bigger but they do
spend a lot of their time actually
getting food okay so the thing about how
to gather existence as you probably
would have seen is very gender yes and
you say you know do I want to send us
all back to the kitchen of course this
is a loaded term because in small-scale
society and in societies basically
everywhere around the world it is the
women that do the cooking unless you
come to urbanized modern industrial
nations and so the women are very much
committed to that and the men have
options that that is the the way the
sort of food politics works if the when
want to go hunting they'll go hunting if
they want to go off and look for a
girlfriend and neighboring camp they'll
do that they didn't do that I hasten to
add okay well you know but they did you
several times they spent an awful lot of
time smoking some substance in their
pipes I have to say Thank You Claude
Fishler you are a professor of sociology
and anthropology in in Paris one thing
that the heads are Bay also showed us in
Tanzania is that food is more than just
mere survival it does hold insights into
hierarchy and culture you know in that
particular society and I noticed that
the women did sit separately from the
men but it was also very egalitarian
society the women if the men didn't get
any animal catch an animal hunting they
would share everything they had equally
you know and then they you know the
route the berries and so on so what role
does food playing our lives in helping
tell us something about the cultural
hierarchical and values of a society you
know come to think of it it's not just
as well as you said survival thats Sarah
I would say we are what you eat what we
eat quite literally biologically
speaking because everything we put in
our bodies becomes not just is not just
burnt as
whereas energy it's also the building
blocks of our very substance for a part
so we are what we eat and we are what we
eat in a imaginary symbolics magical
sense in the sense that there is this
heuristic you know this way of thinking
that is apparently universal that what
you eat makes you feel or look like what
you're eating that is what you eat is
sort of changes you from the inside I
mean you just have to look at
advertising commercials about foods they
use that all the time I remember an old
commercial in France about avian water
mineral water it said something like if
young gives you what the mountain gave
it so what in the world does mountain
the mountain give the water it's
probably something I don't know purity
of the of the water that flows from the
glaciers or is something that closer to
the to this the two heavens something
like that but anyway you are what you
eat in this very sense so what is really
crucial and that's also a universal is
that people want to know what they're
eating it's been said in so many words
this month this morning very seriously I
mean we want to know what we eat because
if we are what we what we eat we want to
know what we eat if we don't know what
we eat we don't know what we are i mean
and we feel threatened and we are
anxious for us for our relative that
we're responsible for that sort of thing
so this is the common problem I mean in
in the West now in the West in the
developed world I don't like to talk
about the West because the so-called
Western countries are very different
from each other most of them and the
common problem is that there's a growing
challenge associated with the processing
of our food the dissidents the retail
system the specialization of the global
ecosystems instead of the diversified
local ecosystems and people don't know
where their food comes comes from and
they're concerned about that they don't
know what's in there they you can put
labeling on
to change much actually it increases
anxiety if anything and we'll can see
situation we will come to we are what we
eat in a moment when I speak to
Elizabeth but in terms of how food helps
is a kind of vehicle for manifestations
of cultures values its hierarchy I said
the heads are we had a very egalitarian
approach to the way they at I mean not
all societies or communities are
necessarily egalitarian and just there
for food play a role in helping us see
that it is that an is that illustrative
of well I think that there is something
novel to and that is a part of the world
has turned what was collective into
something that is essentially individual
and that part of the world is probably
very Western I think it's mostly in the
US and the english-speaking world in
general we ran studies with qualitative
quantitative I mean questionnaires
interviews focus groups for years and we
came up with the observation that when
you ask people in places like France
Italy Spain to a certain extent parts of
Switzerland what is eating well they
will typically at one point tell you
something about collective experience of
eating that is a meal that develops in a
normal codified way as a thing that
makes the experience of food fine and
normal and everything and then you have
another view of the world so it's it
turns out that it's mostly Catholic
countries historically Catholic
countries that reason as if the meal was
the center of the food experience and
the meal functions as a ritual and
almost a communion ok so you share into
the food as if it was the Eucharist you
know the blood and the
and the flesh of Christ so you're not
going to ask questions about whether the
the flesh of Christ has gluten or not I
mean you know you're not going to be
fussy i think i think i'm still working
you see what I mean now what about the
Protestant historically Protestant I
mean it has nothing to do with with
actual religious practice but it's just
something that is inscribed in in in in
cultures max favorites so it so the
Protestants have a different view they
think it's all about individuals meeting
the meal is just a meeting of two or
several individual free wills so it's a
contract it's not coming I wish it's a
contract so it's all about negotiating
it so I'll eat this and you leave that
and I don't eat this and you don't eat
that and that's that but i have to say
very quickly before I come to listed the
French are monsters aren't they using
food as kind of a way of expressing
their cultural superiority when it comes
to the wonderful banquets that you have
at the elysee palace i'm sure you've
been to one or two where they put their
best foot forward we know about food but
anyway i'll give you a right to reply in
a moment in a moment to in a moment you
can think about that one professor
elizabeth black so i can ponder this
professor blackburn in 2009 you were the
Nobel Prize winner for medicine
physiology prize for your pioneering
work on telomeres telomeres which are
the kind of shoelaces that tie-up
chromosomes if I could say it that way
and you're you have got a huge interest
in you know how health cells stay
healthy and what we can do to promote
the health of ourselves and what we can
do to avoid deterioration and harmful
materials so when we're talking about
the role of food in our lives the road
of food is key isn't it to maintaining
good health and so on does your
scientific background give us any tips
on what we should eat for breakfast
lunch and dinner
haha I'm staying close to your
microphone please yeah you're working
now anybody help the back here me are
you awake so um so tips telomeres are
the tips of chromosomes so nicely yes so
um I think it takes us back to something
really quite profound about about food
which is you know we needed to sustain
us clearly but we also need us needed to
get to full development and recommended
daily intake sand or weekly intakes
I think mine is but I know maybe twice
what Mike if I think that would be
rather laborious process it's been kind
of stuck to my neck up here right so um
yes what we know very little about is if
I may yeah yeah so we we do know that
having what is generally regarded us you
know fairly fruit and fiber and
vegetable rich and you know you know not
too much highly processed sugary foods
that's associated with better
maintenance of telomeres and that in
turn in adult populations over and over
again is associated with if your
telomeres a better maintained throughout
the decades of now adult life then your
risks and we're talking statistical
risks of things I cardiovascular disease
diabetes now lung diseases now even
Alzheimer's started to be related to
this in ways where there's real
causality in there there's a
contribution so it matters so what's
interesting is that we've got these
generalizations we know in general what
sorts of foods are better but what's
fascinating to me is that how very
little we understand about what's
actually best for us as we go through
all our life course is the food that you
eat from you know 70 to 90 or something
really the food that is optimal for when
you're you know 20s and 30s or optimal
for when you're in your 40s 50s and 60s
it's a completely unknown so to me I
think what we should aspire to is say
well food is such a similar part of our
lives we should aspire to saying let's
actually try and find this out and with
the sorts of technologies in ways you
can measure things this is not crazy
anymore right accenture understand so
then we could talk about the details
around that but i think we we have a
pretty basic question that we don't know
we're using stuff but we don't even know
if it's really that good and that's the
confusion that we talked about the
recommendations that confuses all right
because there was an article which cited
you as saying that you thought there was
mileage in this argument which is that a
vegan
it is one that does promote a healthy
lifestyle and therefore either yeah
that's okay but I wouldn't be nearly so
that that's where there's some data
right which are pretty consistent but
that to me is not prescriptive saying
you have to be vegan because you could
probably very well and disperse that
with all sorts of things believe me I
ate co baby for the first time in my
life a few weeks ago and I thought that
was pretty delicious but I'm not going
to make a life habit of it so I think
one could really mix it up quite I had
lunch with you your secrets are safe but
so I think it's trends of what you'll
eat rather than you know fussing over
the individual that I think that's heard
by the more I wonder if you've looked at
the the this year's Nobel Prize winner
for medicine or physiology professor
yoshinori asumi because he wanted prize
for developing our knowledge of
autophagy yes which is kind of when so
you thought yourself in it comes from
that week doesn't he has a good thing to
do better well this is verizon ask you
yeah i mean we've known about otology
for the last 50 years or so but he
helped us understand and painless but
you know explain it and so he part of
the minutes it's the way cells recycle
recycle they won't get rid of harmful
material as well as we cited a good and
it was put to him that as people got
older some kind of calorie reduction in
what they eat would help promote healthy
cells from where another and i met him
and I asked i asked him whether because
if there were reports that he himself
practiced this kind of you know not
starvation diet but certainly kept his
calorie intake low for at least part of
the week and whether this would promote
better health and he said it's been
proven in mice but not in human i can
tell you a story it's marvelous and it's
actually very interesting as long as
it's not too long because i got to get
to eduardo but go on age of food aid
your food within a 12 hour period and
make sure there's about a 12-hour space
between say you know evening feel food
and breakfast and there's really lovely
data in mice cognitive behavior and all
sorts of other health measures much
better and beginning data in humans so
it's have a nice big gap between dinner
and
breakfast you see you getting all these
health tips similar calories similar
cal's remand Nobel scientist laureate
they said those guide the Salk Institute
who found this beautifully in mice and
so now we answered this data coming out
of you you know I have to say it's very
quickly all my life I've never eaten
breakfast it is something I why you look
so in such good shape said it because
it's clearly working just say my living
evidence I'm alive experiment lifelong
experiment i can tell you i won't say
how we told longitudinal but it's N
equals 1 so we need more really it'd be
more of you yeah ever since I was an
infant I've never eaten breakfast asking
my agent now unlike that woman who's
asked how old she was she said she's
approaching 50 but wouldn't say from
which direction is awesome what but I
have never eaten breakfast that I
regularly go for 10 or 12 hours without
eating and yeah so anyway thank you very
answer eduardo nielsen hello to you so
you are the vice coordinator for food
and nutrition at the Brazilian Ministry
of Health and you're an expert in salt
reduction I said I had lunch with you as
well but your secret is also safe with
me now when we're talking about the role
of food in our lives says also we talked
a bit about the cultural aspect i wanted
to just touch on that in terms of
brazilians because there you are this
wonderful mixed in a 180 million people
what are you whatever 100 million you
want to me or whatever yes so and you're
what this wonderful mix of european and
indigenous and african and so on so you
know the role of food there helps tell
us the kind of history of Brazil yes
truly does and it's a firstly I will
approach a concern that we have
unfortunately we as all ministers
ministries of Health around the world we
work a lot with disease and that's not
what it should be and we see all the
relation between their food habits that
are changing replacing the traditional
foods for the industrialized ultra
processed foods and that's directly
correlated to chronic disease to
increasing obesity and also to not
having enough micro nutrients and I
that's all associated because it's a
whole food pattern
going on but on the other hand we do
have all of this heritage or the culture
behind it and Brazil is a very vast
country and has had immigration and also
the indigenous populations mixing
together and that's how I can actually
build many different food cultures in
the country and the most interesting
interesting part is that we found that
each one of them this in its uniqueness
it has is healthy because it was built
to that as the food has their own
history of being non-random group of
nutrients we do have the meals having
the same meaning so they evolved
culturally and sociologically through
time and that brings us to a whole
mixing pot which is Brazil but with all
the differences and we see that each
region has different foods and actually
you can build very healthy diet centene
each one of them and that's what I
actually have how our food Baker food
guidelines were built because we were
able to see any in each region what were
healthy foods people were eating so it's
very feasible right so we're talking to
Elizabeth hear about the link between
food and health so you are concerned now
in Brazil because as there's growing
affluence amongst some communities in
the country they're shifting from those
traditional foods to more of a Western
diet and that's really increasing the
level of communicable diseases diabetes
obesity I think you said it's tripled in
the last 20 years imagine tripled in the
last 20 years in Brazil because of this
shift in diets so I wonder if you could
just tell us a bit more about that yeah
it's something that we should just be
actually because the rice and beans
vegetables in meat which are a staple
food in Brazil it has the mix it in
these different cultures but it's
actually is so protective to the heart
as is the Mediterranean diet there are
studies going on Brazil is proved that
it's very important to see that you
don't have to switch to yourself to a
different context you have the right
food so to say the healthier foods and
in your own context and that helps us to
actually address the people to show that
what they can do is part of the real
lives and part of the foods they access
but also has a policymaker we had to
health only with actually receive the
outcomes from all in terms of the
diseases and everything but if we want
to promote health ramat promote healthy
diets we have to influence the other
policies as well from production to
distribution to income because it's all
together people how to access to food
but healthy food is sure I mean one
thing that I suppose your best place to
raise it on this panel because you're
the only person who represents a country
that's not a developed country I suppose
still defined as a developing countries
the role of food that the role that food
plays in development and of course in
Brazil you've been pioneers in the
what's known as the conditional cash
transfers the familia bolster you call
it in Oh bolsa famlia in in Brazil
whereby poorer families families with
below average income are given cash by
the government and it's generally given
to the women who had the households and
they use it predominantly to buy food
and that it of course improves their
family's well-being so food does play a
role in health indicators but also that
contributes into a country's development
yeah it sure does i think that Brazil
has tackled ma nutrition both wasting
and stunting in children and in in a
decade we have that like increase
reduced to half what we had in stunting
is something that was thought to be with
done in a generation but it has to do
with all the context working with social
policies but including the the income
but income with education with the whole
sanitation and all the environment going
on so people actually do purchase foods
because that's the main priorities for
the families and it's something very
interesting that we found it analyzing
some data is that we're not only
protecting the children from stunting
and wasting but we're also protecting
them from overweight by adding the
purchase of food local foods being
produced layer and also the education
because education is behind everything
in terms of child care and having the
rug the best choices for them to
I'm love ya go back it you just said
something very interesting there which
is local producers because that's
another aspect of this conversation
which is local food producers often need
some kind of help so that it's not just
the big food corporations that dominate
the market and so on so that is also an
important aspect of what you've done
that yes it is and it's something that
we've actually been working on thinking
about obesity is the same with improving
the food markets of the at the local
level but also what could new bass
government's from the federal state or
municipal levels that we hadn't have
procurement policies for example as we
have in school there's something very
important that you have
let's see if mines working yeah yeah
it's coming back there you go very still
don't move where we have created a rule
that not not only for for the school
feeding program which is our on the
country and it actually attends millions
of school-aged children in Brazil we
have the nutrition culture York of
course that privileges most natural
foods but it's something very important
at the local level the procurement
policy requires that at least thirty
percent of the foods must be bought from
family agriculture smallholders and
local
and though okay I'll stay them back and
they live actually produced the the
foods that have produced locally but
also that accepted by the culture
there's something that belongs to that
the whole community and so it gave it
all the sense of mixing it all together
and bringing education with food and
everything right well there you are
audience up have I got microphones in
the audience for people to put points
two microphones if you could there's a
young man there I see another show of
hands so than the two day
because what make what makes us human is
cooking food and that helped us in our
development we also share food actually
because primates don't share food do
they they just snatch it we do like my
children like my kids do yeah my four
children don't ever share they just grab
the food so heard about food and yet how
it defines us as being human beings
we've heard about food as a kind of
cultural social and biological force
what it tells us about in food and the
links between food nutrition and health
and then a bit of that as well as food
is a critical factor in development so
please let's get it we you be so kind as
to stand young man that would be great
introduce yourself and your organization
if relevant in hello I'm my name is
Martin RB and I'm doing research about
agricultural how agriculture is
influencing the global economy and you
talked a bit about the vegan diet and
the health and how it influences the
health and there is something called the
IDF gene which prolong which longer the
life of a cell by twice so my question
for you is and to triggered a gene you
can eat a vegan diet so my question is
what why do people choose to eat things
that are bad for them and what can we do
to help people make good choices all
right thank you will keep that question
in mind we'll come to it we need a
psychologist on the on the panel don't
leave but I think that's going to be one
for you the order thank you will keep
that pass the microphone to the other
person who wanted to ask a question yeah
is there other two microphones yep thank
you if you could give the unless you
want to ask a question I would recommend
you relinquish it to who wanted to ask
questions
I know you've got one who else anybody
else okay there's one at the back there
but it's okay we'll get that one to go
go go hello I'm Ivana master's student
in a strategic communications and I
wanted to ask you if i'm not wrong i
know so far brazil is the only country
in Latin America that have implemented a
sustainable eating guide um has that
been able to implemented successfully in
a country that still have so many
challenges and people may have still
other priorities than eating healthy
maybe path from the eating healthy to
eat and sustainable and how's that been
done thank you just pass the microphone
behind you if you'd be so kind young
lady thank you and then we'll come to
the panel yeah hi I'm Divya Rajput okay
I'm a journalist from India my question
is for the sociologists there the whole
talk about healthy eating and you know
sustainable eating you think do you feel
that the old cultural aspect of food
probably might get lost because of this
you know the fact that we are seeing
about you know what we're here for is
that there's something that you worry
about right so you do the latest eating
fads are they going to what did you say
now the whole the stress on eating
healthy food is that going to take away
the cultural aspects of what we've been
eating it for the many many years what
do you eat then that's unhealthy but
culturally sound sorry what do you eat
that's culturally sound but is unhealthy
oh well don't know i mean indian food is
congealed food it's my might some might
say that it's not healthy too much rice
when there is so much good things that
sort of made out of one of those rice in
a lot of oil lot of spices which
probably i think is not we would not
call it healthy increase world oh why do
you know i love a curry carry on eating
it fine if I may be so bold panels to
answer that one so let's go to you than
eduardo how sustainable this sustainable
healthy diet that's been introduced in
so has it really been implemented
properly it's actually it's a dietary
guideline which is it supposed to be
sustainable healthy and socially just so
it we try to get all this together it's
not only about environment but I think
that we are healthy diet should be based
on the production which would should be
sustainable but also produce social de
justice on the way that's why I like we
acknowledge so much that the role of
local producers and the local circuits
and how it could get all of these foods
together so it's actually a challenge to
do that because first of all you will be
facing the big industry all around
because it's mainstream all in in all
places but on the other hand we had to
have a lot of scientific evidence so
we're working on that through working in
producing healthy settings and
subsidizing regulation which is needed
in some cases both to make an
environment that provides better access
to healthy foods but also to avoid
unhealthy choices and information the
population because it has to go in all
levels so people are informed and it's
actually something that addressing the
first question if I ever yeah if y'all
come back to that one to you you can
answer better I just come to Claude
maybe do you want to answer why people
eat the wrong thing the first question
from the young man no you don't know do
they do they really you know my point is
I mean societies of the past that we're
eating the wrong thing probably aren't
here anymore and on the other hand we
some we'd see more adaptation than the
opposite we see that Mexican Mexicans
cook their tortilla mazur Dow in water
that is add with with ashes and it makes
the lysine and the tryptophane the amino
acids in the maze bioavailable okay when
you ask them what why they do it what do
they say they say I don't know we've
always done it this way or they say well
it tastes better or something like that
which is disputable so
in other words but that's not the point
the ash is bad for you is at the point
know that it's good for you if it makes
the maze yeah but he asked me might
easily wouldn't matter why do you treat
bad thing but I think that the the bad
things there are nowadays we decide that
but some things are bad and we can
probably identify them but the truth is
that our life expectancy has increased
for instance in Western Europe and but
something like 20 years since 1936 so if
it was that bad you know I heard last
year for the first time they said that
the life expectancy in France had been
decreasing so I looked up the data and I
have a former student who's into these
things and it turns out that it's about
people over 65 because they weren't
doing their their flu shots ah i see
nothing to do with it because that's the
anti-vaccine movement or that sort of
thing sure it is but do you want to
answer yet why do people eat the wrong
things very specifically if we if we say
wrong things include very high sugar
content refined sugar content it turns
out and sometimes high fat there's a
pretty adaptive response to stress which
is that so I'll tell you what happens in
the lab and we didn't do this work but
i'll just tell you if you stress rats
very mildly not you're not being really
mean to them but you just do it day
after day after day you know you'd make
them sort of sit a little area for a
while and not run around and so on and
they get very stressed out and then you
give them equal access to either really
junk high-fat high-sugar food or just
regular catcher rat chow then what they
do is the stressed ones as opposed to
the unstressed ones they code for that
high sugar high fat instant energy food
and they don't need that many more
calories that's about the same but
that's very adaptive responsive urine
stress you need to have a response to be
able to respond quickly so it's built
into our physiology and then it starts
setting up reward centers in the brain
to these high sugar things too so
there's physiology there and if we
understand it we get away from the blame
game we have to say we recognize it and
then we figure out ways in which one can
you know cook with interest I have it
very sweet to it's not my fault so
Richard Wrangham do primates like sweet
things chimps gorillas our closest
relatives yeah i mean the the reason
that that we like all these bad things
is we haven't had the opportunity to
have them in the past but but all
primates absolutely adore sugar and many
of them really like fat so the reason
that we like them so much of course is
that there were never enough of them in
the in the past all wild animals in my
experience are hungry all the time
humans are in a completely new world of
being able to satisfy the their food
desires on a regular basis so the
solution of course is not to make these
things so available whether or not
that's a politically acceptable solution
is a different matter sugar tax yeah
exactly don't take around um I bother
you want you to come in green like I
gotta go Jess sorry girl I what I said
is not you know it's not enough at me
sound wrong I mean what when people eat
things that are bad for them it's
basically that they cannot afford much
else and I'll give you a very brief
example of what what I mean I had access
to a subsample of an American sample of
what they call working poor usually
often single women and this is in the
city of columbus ohio single women with
children they're juggling three or four
different jobs they don't own a car in a
city where Trent public transportation
isn't exactly comfortable and and common
so what happens they come home in the
evening that aren't going to do
extensive shopping they're going to go
for the stuff that has the most calories
for the least dollars that will be
enjoyable for the children that have
that are going to sit in front of the TV
and it will come in bags and they won't
have to cook and the kids will be quiet
interesting so we had that question from
the young lady from India your final
thoughts Elizabeth and gentlemen on
that issue and just incorporate your
parting shot so you know if things are
indigenous to a culture the food has
been built up as a tradition over many
centuries and yet some people might say
it's a little bit harmful because it's
high in saturated fats or cooked in oil
or deep-fried or whatever there is a
role that food plays in our lives which
is we mustn't lose sight lose sight of
the fact that it is enjoyable and that
you want to hang on to things which your
grandparents and forefathers and
foremothers have eaten isn't that right
your final thorn it well that's very
true i think the key that we found in
based on our experience not only brazil
but i could speak i actually promotes
latin american countries is that we need
to diversify the diet that's something
that is in the very root of addressing
y'all from obesity to malnutrition to
even cry a micronutrient deficiencies
because all cultures have that built
this over time both in terms of the food
they eat the meals lead and so it's all
part of the same in that actually
addresses what was spoken about the
stresses of eating healthy that we have
to learn it's something you don't have
to overthink actually but do you have to
fight so to say against the system
because there's a lot of advertising on
bad food and people so people need
information they need to know about the
cost what is the supply system of food
and yeah we must have different pictures
are not in America it's actually cheaper
to have a healthy diet then Nazca in
other countries so you have to work with
that and yeah if you had your last meal
what would your last meal be I really
like fruits and vegetables are innocent
veg with spice all right you Claud final
point do we don't take the joy out of
food and once you so much for bringing
this up yeah but not a minute I wanted
to make that statement I think we've
heard so much about health and so much
about the world and the environment and
so little about joy and pleasure out of
eating and it what makes our life part
of what makes our life enjoyable is the
food we eat and share and
and enjoy and taste you too love to be
French normal thank you and sometimes I
think of myself as a professional French
in this regard yeah the way yeah what's
your final favorite meal your final dish
I mean that's if you know it's always
lately food and gastronomy have been a
lot about discovering creativity and
everything and I find myself becoming
more and more conservative and more and
more along the Proust approach you know
they see what memories from the back to
my childhood it was Blanca de vous you
have to tell people what that is
something to do well it's a very basic
family dish in France that almost
everybody will my toes will get the
recipe afterwards lot of Elizabeth yeah
variety make sure there's you know
plenty of plants in there but my
favorite meal which I hope to die with
is the one from a page which is 13
courses of tiny tiny tiny little bits of
vegetarian based things incredibly
delicious and so joyful and yet you know
it's the beauty of having wonderfully
tasty food like what we had at lunch
that's so these are nice these little
things we had it when I come to lovely
whichever my last meal yes I'll join you
I'll Richard Wrangham so you know don't
take the joy out of it it's been there
for years and your final meal I might
take the joy out of it so I mean look I
the last 15 years or so have been
absolutely incredible in terms of
raising the amount of food produced in
the world by I think it's thirty percent
of per individual for the world and we
are moving people out of poverty into
increasingly good nutritional status in
general so you know that is all
incredibly exciting yeah the the big
question in the future is how much can
we go on increasing survival as opposed
to or having to focus on the issues of
survival as opposed to on the other end
or altogether focusing on sheer pleasure
on the development of new exotic ways to
cook our food
through molecular gastronomy or whatever
which is also healthy which is and of
course be designed to be health okay and
your final meal something really really
healthy chocolate brownie with laser
crow yeah i've just finished I'll just
finish where I started which I have to
say is when i was with the heads are a
tribe and I told you how they yet there
was not one overweight person male
female or child amongst them they all
had flat stomachs regardless of war age
they were very lean and healthy looking
him and I said don't you want to go and
be part of modern tanzania in society
and have all other than no no we prefer
to live like this and for the record for
me it would be chicken satay and
chocolate thank you all very much thank
you
[Applause]